- I studied abroad in
Germany, so I know beers.
(upbeat rock music)
- My usual is Keystone.
- Keystone Light has a promotion
where they put gold cans in the box
and you try to find the lucky gold can.
I found the gold can twice.
- And they've been in
college and house parties and
making really good decisions.
- Coors was like, my thing.
- Definitely Tecate.
- But don't get me a
(censor bleep)ing PBR.
- PBR, I think, is a
legitimately delicious beer.
- Bud Light, classic.
- I'm from Milwaukee, I feel strongly
that PBR is a good beer.
- It's got a nice frothiness to it.
- Smells like beer pong.
- I don't think this is Bud Light.
- This tastes pretty good.
- I'm thinking this
might be the Tecate one?
(unpleasant buzzer)
- Is this one Coors?
- I feel like this is, like, Coors Light.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- Coors Light.
- This is Bud Light.
(happy bell ring)
- Bet I'll know when it's Bud Light.
- This one smells like feet.
- It's even less flavor.
- That one has a little more flavor.
- This is water with,
like, a nice sour nut.
- This I think is Keystone.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- This has to be Keystone.
(unplesant buzzer)
- Coors Light.
(happy bell ring)
- Coors? I don't know.
- Oh, I don't like this one at all.
- I don't know, they all
taste so frickin' similar.
- It has a nice oak flavor, I don't know,
I don't know how they do it.
- It has no flavor, except old.
- God, this is so hard.
- Coors.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- I have no (censor bleep)in' clue.
Tecate?
(unpleasant buzzer)
- Is that Tecate?
- I'm gonna swirl it.
- That tastes like absolutely nothing.
- Man, I'm, I'm shocked at how
indistinguishable these are.
- This one's got some nice foam goin' on.
- Elvis, did you pour all the same one
(man laughing off screen)
just to trick me?
- This one reminds me of
going on a dinner date
with a guy in Silver
Lake, so I'm pretty sure
this is PBR.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- Maybe this is PBR.
- I'll say this is Bud Light.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- Oh, this one's a little
darker than the others.
- I can't be too indecisive,
or else I'll just get drunk.
- Hmm, this one actually has a flavor.
- Okay, this one tastes like a
little bit of Spanish flavor.
So I'm gonna say the Tecate is this.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- I like that one.
- This one's pretty good.
- I'll say that's Natty Light.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- This might be Stone.
- This one's the PBR.
(happy bell ring)
- I'm gonna say this is PBR.
- (whispering) They all
start to taste the same.
- Now I'm number six, I'm like, "Hey."
- Oh, that one tastes like weed.
- Mmm, that one's like, tangier.
Maybe that one's Coors.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- I think it's probably Coors.
- PBR.
(unpleasant buzzer)
- Anyone who says they can
tell the difference between
all these beers, I don't trust
any of their life decisions.
- Tecate?
Oh, okay, well I knew I was
gonna like PBR and Tecate.
- This is Keystone.
No, I didn't wanna like PBR.
The one thing I feel strongly about
is that PBR is overrated.
- Ugh, okay, I have to stop this game
'cause I'm getting buzzed.
This one's my favorite, I'm
pretty sure it's Keystone.
Oh, maybe I like Coors Light.
- This is Bud Light. (knocks on cup)
This one is the best.
Oh, (censor bleep), all the
comments are gonna be like,
"Look at these hipsters with their PBR."
- This one definitely tasted
like it had the most to it.
PBR.
Well, I guess I like Tecate
better than I thought.
- Yeah, this one's my
favorite, is it Coors?
I chose the hipster beer that
I refuse to drink at parties,
and it's my favorite one.
I've failed the hipsters,
I've failed Germany,
I've failed my mom in some way, probably.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah, mm hmm.
(door slams)
(uptempo drum music)
Oh.
You don't know the half of it.
(bossa nova music)